Now, one important little gotcha here, which I'm sure didn't actually fall
through your example, was the calling of this dot world dot clear forces every
frame. Now this is an important point in our physics engine implentation.
Typically, in a physics engine, you'd set the velocity, toss around some
objects and be on with your day. The reason for this is that box 2D assumes
that you're in a two dimensional environment with the gravity vector always
pointing down. As such if you were to create an object and throw it through the
world, the gravity forces on it would actually move it downward. However in
grids this is not the correct policy. What we'd like to do is for a projectile
to move forward along a straight path without vertical gravity influencing it.
However, because we're a top down game and don't have a gravity vector, any
small velocity vector gets accumulated on our physics object each frame without
friction allowing it to continue bouncing around in the environment. Or rather,
you should think of gravity as something that produces friction on an object,
slowing its velocity. We fixed this sort of gliding, hockey puck motion by
reducing the influence of the physics engine on our world. Namely, we allowed
the velocity of an object to be set for a given frame, the physics engine to
move that object and compute the position and rotation and collisions. And at
the end of the frame, we erase and remove that velocity vector. Now unless we
reapply a velocity vector to the next frame, the object will sit in this
position not moving.